what's up reject nation i'm greg and i'm
john with dc fandom coming up in a few
weeks
snyder cut trailer supposedly coming out
that's what zack snyder saying
i figured you know what would be fun to
do is do some revisiting of what led up
to justice league originally
starting with everything great about man
of steel from the awesome channel
cinema wins and we actually covered our
first cinema wins video a couple months
ago we got hit up by the man himself
very
very endearing positive loving twitter
message exchange
so uh how's it going buddy thank you for
having our back on covering your video
being so lovely we have our nice mics
right now when time allows for it we'll
try to use these as
a little bit more often i just felt like
using them today we'll switch back to
these
when we're reviewing what cinema wins is
talking about anywho
let's get into it
[Music]
i've got to say the weird 3d magnetic
liquid stuff is a unique piece of
imagine tech so
is everything all right i said girl
cogino to the rescue
yeah this is the moment i realized
snyder wasn't using slow-mo he
definitely would have used it there i
imagine nolan producing must have played
it
down is a visually well developed world
unexplained advanced technology distinct
architecture
fantasy-like animals the kryptonians
keep as pets and arrogant self-righteous
inhabitants
and the carvings on the codex give us a
sense that there's an extensive history
to this world
that's what you get for messing with
maximus are you
not entertained that's what you get for
messing with somebody guys
so cool
this version of zod is another villain
with a purpose we'll see throughout that
he's not just twirling his mustache
trying to win world domination or settle
a personal vendetta
mostly he's just concerned with the
future of a species this is a pretty
great wormhole transportation thing
they've built like nothing i've ever
seen
the destruction of krypton is done
masterfully and believably
zimmer do i hear a little interstellar
score in there or i guess i heard some
man of steel score and interstellar
either way the entire score is beautiful
especially superman's new theme
nice touch to have the man of steel be a
placeholder for an actual piece of steel
also just win seagull struggling in the
wind
a little foreshadowing me thinks not
that the size of soup's muscles has
anything to do with his strength but
it's nice to finally see a shredded and
imposing force that is henry cavill and
chest hair said he really wanted to
pretend like this is the first superman
film and not take anything for granted
that being said i think he and goier did
a phenomenal job of keeping the
smallville teen part of this story brief
and the segways to both flashbacks are
seamless you were sitting here
yeah that's fair what a perfect example
of humanity's narcissism to interpret
two parents sending their child off
their
planet to save him from death as an
answer to our problems and not the other
way around
my son this has to be the best paw camp
we've gotten to date
no i agree sure clark seems
mild-mannered but seriously he's still
as wide as a door
come on but clark gets a restraint win
all right i take the restraint win back
but i'll replace it with two manners
lessons wins
hilo now gata and not one but two snyder
movies zach has to be a battlestar
galactica fan
helping a new friend that's a scotch
straight up for the lady
great drink order and a great mustache
on bizarro daniel
the superman suit is handled perfectly
it isn't worshipped it's barely even
explained
just the symbol it just is and it's
still as impactful as ever
this entire scene superman gets a
stunning visual introduction while his
powers are explained and teased and hans
zimmer gives us all good party
nipples right there when he realizes he
might just push a lot harder
his excitement is perfect his child like
learning to walk for the first time
he reminds us that he's just a kansas
farm boy who found out he could fly
an indestructible kansas boy but uh
kansas point nonetheless
there's never been this much power
behind superman so i'm starting to think
that snyder's compromise on no slow-mo
was snap zooms
but it's cool
yep that's about as cool as flying gets
as misguided as pokhen's reasoning may
have been he still sacrificed himself
for his son
so you know what that means it sucks but
this is the second of two very
tastefully done deaths the first being
lara
i get why they had henry do so many pain
yells he really sells it i didn't know
doug stamper could even smile
genuinely creepy alien invasion is a
welcome change for a superman conflict
you just have to decide what kind of man
you want to grow up to be clark
there's a pretty clear anti-bullying
message in this movie which is great i'm
just not sure how it applies to anyone
who isn't superman
such a sick reveal
steel man i'm not exactly sure how dream
sharing works for kryptonians
but since zod seems to be running the
show i assume he's in control
assuming that assumption i love that he
puts clark in human clothes
serves two purposes i know who you
really are and i'm superior to you
exactly what a military leader would do
still the most powerful superman we've
ever had but still has the ability to be
gentle
perfect mix also more flawless wire work
from snyder
now begins the place people start really
complaining superman starts destroying
everything with no concern for human
life
here's the thing though we all have this
feeling like superman has been
supermanning for seven decades because
for us he has
but this is his first fight literally
the first time he's punched anyone
he just barely started testing out his
powers of course he's going to be a full
in a china shop
also and possibly more importantly zod
just trashed his parents house and
threatened his mother
sorry he's going to be a little unhinged
also in his defense he destroyed a smoke
stack and a gas station and tells people
to get inside
it's not safe it's the stupid americans
who start shooting up smallville
well and zotz group faster than a
speeding bullet
the great fight great fight centerfield
feyora is the real menacing villain here
so calm and collected
who cares if they're destroying
everything this fight isn't me
exactly thank you
ask bad girl in addition to the snap
zoom snyder traded slow-mo for these
speed-ups
the story is zack snyder hates things at
normal speed but fayor
great it's like an anime locomotive
yep this man is not our enemy
you all got a little choked up turtle
nathan hardy wait
where's the tie fighter this ship is
powered by something called a phantom
drive
it bends space and the flux capacitor is
what makes time travel possible
got it
you win zimmer you win maybe there's no
reason for this to work but sheer force
of will has always been superman's
strongest asset
also saving earth if you destroy this
ship
you destroy krypton zod is a villain
but his motivations aren't evil he's a
villain with some real depth
chance all the talk of free will and
choosing your own destiny comes to a
head right here
superman chooses earth over krypton
[Music]
yep again with the unconventional flying
i don't think i've ever seen someone
start flying from the face down position
oh yeah good call lex corey that's good
guy you'd better not let us down jesse
eisenberg
i was dread to be a warrior cow trained
my entire life
and that line should really be enough to
shut up all the critics superman had no
training he's a newborn superhero
obviously he was gonna break some
buildings
the flying in this movie has done better
than ever before as well you get a real
sense of speed and agility
[Music]
but that's why you don't wear a cape you
better not let us down ben affleck
explain all you want about the
destruction of metropolis this is one of
the best
fight scenes ever put to media it has
actual hand-to-hand comment on the
ground combined with flying throwing
hand-to-hand comment in the air and even
a space battle
and it's filmed in a very fresh way and
now we come to the final reason this
film gets so much hate
personally i think it's right in line
with what this film is about the free
will of a mortal albeit unbreakable man
a man that seeks out religious advice
when he's unsure a man who doesn't
believe himself to be a god the way all
kryptonians do
a grounded flawed new man who tries to
change the outcome but ultimately has to
choose to end zod's life to do what he
believes is right she should talk about
their opportunities david talked about
but zod promised
discussions the only course of action he
deemed just
a bold statement that upset lots of
people but this isn't your grandfather
superman
[Music]
and it clearly weighs heavily on him i
grew up in kansas general
about as american as it gets the
superman exists and he is american
your shoulders be able to bear the
weight yeah atlas ain't got nothing on
clark
they stuck a superman pose in there
after all welcome to the planet
this movie is ultimately an origin story
for clark kent and i have no problem
with lois knowing his identity right
from the get
it happens eventually anyway so get on
with it and it feels a lot more
believable
as recently man of steel received
overwhelmingly positive reviews upon its
release
and then slowly but surely the hater
started creeping out of the woodwork
is this a perfect film that should go
down as the best superhero film of all
time not necessarily
but the flaws that have been complained
about are mostly less than nitpicking
jonathan kent's death was tough but it
made sense within the confines of the
movie
the utter destruction in the final
battle was nothing more than an honest
depiction of two unbreakable beings
trying to break each other amongst
breakable
things yeah superman wasn't negligent he
was outnumbered outmatched and he just
learned to fly like what a few weeks
before having to save the earth
besides all that snyder wanted there to
be a high death toll he wanted zod's
attack to have some gravity to it pun
intended
dc's universe is not the mcu superman
has been a boy scout for the last 70
years
aren't we ready to see him be grounded
in a little more reality we all
resoundingly agreed that nolan's batman
was what we wanted
we're in the golden age of comic book
movies because of it iron man set up a
spectacular world for the avengers
man of steel did not fall short of doing
the same for the justice league
and since we're liable to hit saturation
points in the next one this video comes
out i'm
glad the dc u is going in a different
direction than the mcu
not every cast was perfect but michael
shane and zod is fully competent even if
he was outshined by ancient trials
feyora
man she's awesome manpo can't definitely
met if not surpassed every other
representation of those characters
and henry cavill is about as soups as we
can ask for especially in this new
universe where he's a growing learning
conflicted real character
this portrayal of the last temptation of
christ style
last temptation choices have
consequences and i believe that the
choices he made in this movie will go on
to affect every film in the dc eu
on zimmer score in this film is
phenomenal
the villains theme puts you on edge and
superman's theme added a feeling of new
beginnings in anticipation to the
triumphant score of the past
other than that i have no worries about
dawn of justice i have complete
confidence that nolan snyder and goyer
won't let us down
now batfleck could be a different story
but
wow this came out 2016 of march and
well good will hunting i guess what's
really more damon
uh armageddon pearl harbor
reindeer games really never mind we're
screwed
i just think he's kind of hot
next week we'll watch his bbs let's see
how
see if he retracted any of these
statements probably he's the kind who
would if he
if he really does feel like he what he
anticipated he was wrong about
an honest cat that's an honest guy
that's an open-minded guy too
yeah that was great
so cool makes me just want to go right
back and watch man of steel again
let's get the mics on well this is
fascinating to do because
um doing some quick research this came
out march 25th 2016.
the day this video was published so
obviously he was spending some time
writing it prepping it bvs came out
march 25th 2016. so he publishes the day
that batman v superman came out we're
now in 2020
of july and it's so fascinating to see
the trajectory specifically would not
not just the dc universe but zack snyder
the association with that because man of
steel he's right it was mainly positive
reception then it had
backlash and now especially this year
there's like seems to be this really big
uprising for like it's so underrated
you know so this movie alone has had an
in
just this one has had an interesting
trajectory what it stands for and the
kind of quality of film
that it is i love checking this out
because i i actually never
saw his dc ones that he's done in the
past couple things i want to talk about
some things that stood out to me that he
pointed out that
are usually not the forefront of my mind
or things that haven't really
been like oh yeah that's true of course
um zod dying
and uh i'll i want to switch to what
david s goyer was talking about recently
at the beloved hailed comic-con oh yeah
great success first off with some of the
technical things that uh he brought up
in this video
zack snyder holding back on slo-mo and
instead having a lot of speed up
and snap zooms yeah the best use of
flying
on a technical scale for like the action
sequences alone i gotta give it to man
of steel for hey
the best use of flying like i really
loved how reported at that moment where
superman's laying on the ground and
slowly levitates up it feels
very real like i don't understand
physics i don't understand all that crap
but i felt like
at least the visual effects in stutt
team department were trying to apply
some level of that with this movie yeah
yeah cause especially when you're like
zipping through the city behind him and
you're like up in the air
there are a lot of flying and
disembodied cameras in these kinds of
movies that
feel very unreal and very unachievable
but there's something about the physics
with which they captured his flight
especially in some of the more
intense sequences and using some of
those speed ramps or snap zooms and
stuff like that that really just make it
feel that much more authentic and like
maybe somebody was controlling a drone
or
like a little helicopter behind him or
something like that even just the way
the camera's gonna circle back i thought
they did a nice job thinking about that
and it's good to be reminded of that
because so much of the flight stuff
kind of gets lumped in with the parts of
the movie that people have more problems
with and i think it's easy to overlook
how technically great and he even
pointed out like some of the wire work
and stuff like that is is really
pristine
i think the whole smallville fight is
incredible
that's probably my favorite fight other
than no man's land
that's probably my and and the bvs
warehouse basically there's
it's the top three
one from each different movie the
smallville fights specifically like i
love the little details of when
superman's like trying to escape and one
and i can't remember exactly
if it was feyora the other guy who like
keeps pulling him back down
you know having him by the legs and the
cape and stuff and just the whip pants
that he does it feels like you're
watching
an anime and it really he really seemed
to ask himself what he could do
with the action sequences that we
haven't seen done before yet with
superman and he brought it to life in a
completely different way
we're used to powers like super speed
and super strength
specifically and he was able to show
us a brand new way of capturing it that
could be very visceral
exciting refreshing for superman action
man of steel has down the best i think
one thing that i really had a big
takeaway with this specific video
how much there's additional lived in
rich storytelling just with the visual
elements alone
things i just never picked up on zod's
dream sequence
oh yeah and the clothing that superman's
in and all that and that sort of like
military general thinking of i'm gonna
size you up
and portray you because i know the core
of you and i can use that to belittle
you
exactly like i i never picked up on that
little kind of detail
yeah oh yeah i think understanding those
kind of elements do enhance it the death
of jonathan kent
he didn't really do much to sway me here
in this video specifically the death of
jonathan kent
uh it didn't really bother me when i
first watched it i was wrapped up in the
in the meaning of it
in the moment and the sacrifice all the
things that zack snyder wanted you to
care about
i i was thinking about that when i was
watching the movie the first couple
times to say the least when i look back
on it
i i am like i think clark could have
gone in there he's super fast
i think he could have and i think that
as far as this movie goes that is maybe
one element
that i haven't really been able to
rectify is is especially like paul ken
and just the philosophy
that he puts toward clark throughout the
movie i'm a little bit iffy on and i
think the movie could have done
maybe a little bit more in that
department to flesh it or explain it or
put some
character nuance on top of it just that
one moment i'd say because i think in
terms of the relationship
of jonathan kent and clark kent i love
the way that's fleshed out and i love
kevin costner's portrayal of him
dad am i still your son of course you're
my son oh my god she gets me every time
yeah yeah
yeah yeah and also i'm really glad he
shouted out pharaoh
she's really medicine mvp of the zod
squad
and also with zod being a true villain
someone who
has legit motivation they always say the
best kind of villain is someone who
doesn't view themselves as a bad guy
he's not you really could do a version
of this story that solely captures it
from his perspective
you get his perspective that's it's
being told to you
the movie's not captured from his side
of the story
but you could do a version where he is
definitely the protagonist of his own
story
you know and you could just portray it
as like oh man this guy was just
trying to stick up for for the crumbling
society yeah he's just been you know
orphaned from
like that's his home and he just had a
big set of differences
with jorel on krypton obviously zod he's
the bad guy and
one thing i thought to enhance the alien
element
he does touch on it briefly in here but
when zod arrives on earth and there's
the alien invasion takeover scene that's
cutting around to the new stations and
around the world
while that can be a trope uh in a lot of
movies and such i actually think it's
incredibly effective every time i've
watched this movie and that scene comes
up
it does feel scary and menacing as much
as the movie's like
clark is an alien call l alien that's
when the real debate i really
i feel like even he could have uh honed
in a little bit harder maybe like
nowadays if he made the video now he may
have
honed in on it a little bit because i
noticed his videos are are longer now he
could have probably honed in a little
bit more on how much that amplified
the whole alien dichotomy of should we
trust superman or not
yeah you know and i think that alien
invasion sequence
really sets up a strong debuggle and
debate from the human perspective
looking from the outside looking in
comparing zod what he's doing the
invasion got call
same race you know you got two different
aliens with two different ideologies in
the same invasive
place i mean yes that goes to further
hone in on you know the whole
destruction
of metropolis and how like superman can
be looked at as being
the problem for it which segues into bbs
since the movie i have
gained a greater appreciation for the
second half because when i first saw it
i
kind of preferred the first half but i
do think there is a lot to that and he
does a nice job of articulating how
there is so much about
superman that isn't formed and is being
formed by this entire experience right
now and yeah the fact that he is being
attacked by a bunch of professionals on
his first day at work
you know and so yeah i do appreciate in
hindsight
taking it from that perspective i think
the movie could have maybe done a better
job putting you in the shoes of just
citizens during all this but it does uh
kind of realistically go what if these
all-powerful beings just showed up and
had a fight here it probably would look
like that would probably be
yeah horribly destructive i mean he
brings up solid
solid points about like what you were
just talking about with paul was just
learning
how to fly or or i wouldn't say call out
i would say clark clark was learning
just
how to fly this is all brand new to him
it's been a mystery
for him his whole life i have no issues
with the smallville fight at all and he
actually did
open up my eyes a lot on the destruction
of metropolis
but the smallville fight i'm like yeah
you know of course it's all going to
[ __ ]
like his mother was just being attacked
his family home thrashed i love when
he's holding down zod through the crop
field he's just punching him
you hurt my mom i forget what he says
but i love that moment
and then with the way the fight goes
down it was like of course it's gonna
lead to some crazy destruction like this
you got super powerful beings yeah who
are fighting each other you got one guy
who's trying to defend it all
yeah and uh same thing with metropolis
and really breaking down
he doesn't have the skill set he doesn't
have all of this yet and we have
ingrained in us as
audience members for decades of what
superman should be like what he should
be aware of what he should be mindful
of during battle sequences like this but
he's got a lot of response
yeah yeah well and as much as across you
know his dc eu films i haven't always
loved what zack snyder does with this
stuff i do think that i have warmed up
to his perspective
on the harshness of these stories
especially when doing new adaptations
because you know it was a big deal when
everyone's like oh not my batman he's
killing people and stuff
going to the next snap i thought that
was another moment where
especially looking at it again just
watching the scene you can feel that
pain and what happens when you have
somebody who
makes it clear to you i'm never gonna
stop you can't imprison me i'm
this is my goal and i'm dedicated to it
as a realization moment of
who to be and who not to be i think that
moment is pretty
rich you know when he snaps zod's neck
and has to it's almost like with great
power comes great responsibility moment
in a way but with
way more you know intergalactic heft
upon it i've
never taken gripe with it i've never
felt
before that side of superman doesn't
kill
because especially looking at this the
way that was going down i'm like well in
the context of the scene what else what
do you really do
yeah the man was never going to stop and
so with that
segway in mind got some screenshots
pulled up in between
re plugging back in the mics of the
interview
uh if you guys haven't listened to it
it's pretty fascinating but we're gonna
strictly focus on the thing that's been
circulating the web where goyer was
talking initially about a possibly
different ending which would have
seen zod frozen in space and he said the
idea was that superman would there was
one of those sort of
cryopods on the ship that ends up
becoming the fortress of solitude that
is able to put zod back into and then
throw out into space
we did talk about it and maybe some
people would have been happier with that
but it felt like a cop-out for the story
that we were telling
based off of the movie we got i don't
really know how that they can't
maybe the vision for would have been
different i mean one part of me goes oh
it would have been cool to still have
michael shannon around though yeah
possibility of his return
um and there was already some
controversy that was met later on with
the fact that they you know they take
zod's body and turn him into doomsday
so you got that i would have loved to
have seen um more michael shannon zod
he goes on to say when he's like
defending the choice of
killing zod he says superman is not
aware of the extent of his powers at all
he's finding somebody who said
i won't stop who said you can't put me
in a prison
i won't ever stop we wanted to put him
in a stalemate he was in this terrible
position and then afterwards he vowed
that he could never do it again it
didn't come out of anger he was forced
into it but that was the one
exactly you see i right you gotta make
it i don't feel like i need to be told
this
it stands for reason that you would have
to make a mistake or a regrettable
decision to
realize probably what a piece of your
morality is about to become yeah exactly
there's this thing in the article
or in the interview we're talking about
how there was a scene they had written
but it wasn't filmed that dealt with
young clark kent and jonathan kent going
hunting and having to kill the deer
dealing with you know the powerful thing
to take a life even if you're forced to
take a life that kind of element and
then this article circled back around to
the grace randolph interview
where she was talking with zack snyder
about the evil superman
i think it's important to quote it right
now for the context of what we're
talking about
uh do i love the evil superman i'm not
100
sure if that's truth other than that i
will say i love the idea of superman
going on a journey with his character i
love the idea of superman having to
reconcile his morality reconcile his
place on earth
reconcile his love affair with lois and
how that affects the way he relates to
humanity and
all those things as we all do with
normal relationships we all have in our
daily lives so i think we see superman
grapple with these things
he becomes a lot more relatable thinking
about the context of that where he was
going with bvs and
and what we at least have an idea of
what he wanted to do with superman
in justice league which we will
undoubtedly see in snyderco
hey even without thinking about sequels
and and setting up the choice
never bothered me i know some purists
really hate it and can never get on
board with this position my superman
but to me uh i've i've never had i've
always taken more gripe with him not
saving
paw ken and then that
yeah just because to me it always read
as like this is just a different take
yeah you know it's not the definitive
take and also yeah we've seen
a more aspirational a more perfect
superman in the past
if it was a human being it would be a
different thing
yeah he was like snap some human's neck
he's about to cook a family
this is essential essentially zod in
this moment is
evil superman and you gotta put him down
yeah yeah
i mean what happens when an unstoppable
force meets in a movie
but yeah i thought this is a great video
that was exciting can't wait to check
out the bvs one next
all right guys well everything great
about man of steel
has the movie grown on you has a lesson
in your eyes you excited for a snyder
cut leave your thoughts down below
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell to get notified
whenever we got a new youtube video up
since it's the end of the month i would
like to shout out all our patrons who
are pledged for our deleted takes in
behind the scenes tier
because there we get you get a name call
out
javier gomez ruby gregory bullock
rosie beatty darth yoda066 natalie doran
jen smith melanie faber
kenny waters justin martin
rk kayla waters
chase gardner deontay w tongue punch
fart box
lb andrew barber sj94
deflated brady sam castle
james smith chrissy roe cree
spencer brianna davidson phillip j smith
jr
josh james nobriga marcus
wardermann carissa body rot aaron
nicholas kevin j coleman joshua ruiz
thank you all you beautiful sons of
[ __ ] and bastards thanks
lovelies hope to see you guys next month
at our patreon
and thank you all consider joining our
patreon at the beginning of august yeah
got some stuff going on there
you